so far in this project I've fallen
victim to selection bias in the I'm only
talking about events like the Germany
conference or things like that which
happened very rarely but give it a lot
of attention to them so makes it seem
like that kind of thing happens all the
time which isn't what this projects
about so this past week I've had three
hours of this theory lectures in the
network and some building three hours of
this atmospheric physics lectures in the
atmospheric physics building and an
awful lot of time here in the college
library or I've actually worked
exclusively this week a lot of time I
first have mix up where I work and I
know that I can but I don't know why but
the moment I just freely like working
the codes library as much as it's
possible to make working in library this
week the work that I've been doing has
been for theoretical physics
we've been looking using functional
calculus and in quantum mechanics and
the link between quantum mechanics in
that formulation and statistical
mechanics it's basically a lot of stuff
that Richard Feynman did we haven't
gotten to his QED type stuff yet but
it's it's that formulation of quantum
mechanics and what we're doing
atmospheric physics is a scattering in
the atmosphere so looking at things like
Rayleigh scattering my scattering that
kind of thing actually after the lecture
this week I was chatting to the lecture
about geoengineering and he's involved
in this project which proposes to cool
the planet so to reverse anthropogenic
climate change by injecting aerosols
into the stratosphere the idea being
that you're reflecting light from the
earth so that the earth is radiating
more energy than actually reaches the
planet so the planet starts to cool that
has lots of ramifications and he
actually the great thing about that was
that he is involved in this project then
immediately after the lecture sent us
all the paper that he was talking about
so if you're interested have a look at
this which I printed out on I'll read
later in addition to the work I've been
spending quite a lot of time in the JCR
so a lot of time just sat around talking
to friends Steph still hasn't really got
going I've got two sets of deadlines
this coming Friday which means that now
works properly so I had two weeks of ton
time where things were just kind of
getting started and it was really nice
just to spend that time
not just spells I know to be able to
spend that time in the JCR talking to
friends watching TV spending time in the
bar so on a daily basis what I've been
doing is I reach for my name perhaps
I've forgotten on Monday I had a
rehearsal for my women so mr. one last
week I was in Germany but every Monday I
meet with a bunch of other musicians in
John's College Chapel and we play women
music so I play saxophone and this term
we're doing Paris the Caribbean we're
doing something my son saw from Samson
and Delilah bacchanal we're doing
something by rimsky-korsakov we're doing
some Christmas pieces later in the term
the idea is we're we're kind of unique
in the University in that were a Sinn
Fein wind band so you know playing
orchestral pieces the doesn't audition
and doesn't take yourself too seriously
so it's basically for people who aren't
you get at their instruments at me but
don't like taking things that seriously
and don't want to commit to loads and
loads rehearsal so we rehearse for two
hours a week every week up until the
concert and I mean we put it on and and
we raise a couple hundred pounds and
then that gets reinvested back into the
band we can buy more music music stands
lots of biscuits that's mostly what we
spend it on on Tuesday I had my
meditation class I should point out that
meditation class happens at Keeble
college which isn't known as being one
of the pretty aqua colleges but it looks
like this this and this so it's a
relative scale after that then I had
formal hope so literally hit straight
from him into meditation put on my gown
went on to the Dynel I try to take
footage of each course but I failed
because this was my starter which was a
very nice fruit salad and then we had
nut roast and this kind of very crumbly
thing which was very nice this was just
a bunch of fourth years so a bunch of
people like physicists mathematicians
sciences that kind of stuff it all got
together I just decided to go for four
former Hall
that's very nice it's just over a fiver
it's what six six fifty I think for
three courses and table service
so space you can value and it's just a
nice evening on Wednesday we had the pub
quiz in the bar I might have mentioned
this with
if not we have the best bar in the
university we've actually been vote we
know we were elected by one of the
students papers is like the best college
bar on the university and the reason
that we're the best is because we were
completely student-run we decide what we
put on top or how much we charge for it
so about a pint is like one pound sixty
and lighten ie come from around bath and
there's a brewery by bath which makes a
really nice beer so I asked the bar if
we could get in so we've got a couple of
cakes and now we now we sell that and
it's like one of the people's favorite
bitters in the bar so that's really nice
anyway we had the bar we have a pop quiz
which of course my team won but then
after that it was weird bill I live in
an accommodation block by one of the
rivers in Oxford and this girl fell in
that night and so I had well with a
bunch of people from Paradise Street had
the gun Fisher out which if you're
watching this by the way I really hope
you're okay you looked a bit like a like
a drowned rat last time I saw you but I
hope you're alright on Thursday we had
the physics society talk now I think any
first last time around this time we had
a talk by Yvette Fuentes who is from
Karen which University but she basically
works in relativistic quantum
information so I'll include a link to a
video article about this in the
description but quantum information
theory has to do with this concept of
entanglement and it's really interesting
to actually not that many people were
there but we had a quick Q&A session
afterwards and then there were nibbles
like we do every week next week to talk
looks really interesting it's the title
is does time exist so I'll report back
on now and that should be really
interesting to Friday I don't have any
fuzzy for Friday so don't get your hopes
up a bunch of guys I know went to gym
and then we went to GB cake your bode
kitchen for dinner after that we had a
really nice evening there's more relaxed
day on Friday actually and then on a
Saturday we had up so I spent a lot of
the afternoon trying to think of a
costume failing so each pop is normally
themed so in the past we've had
spc so like come as something that
begins with SPOC we've had the Nintendo
bot
loads of people dressed in his Pokemon
we had a designer uh-huh what else if we
had we have critic you know like
Christmas teen lobster this week was
best of British so I wanted to come as
an RAF fighter pilot can't find a
costume anywhere in Oxford so I just
rocked off in my tuxedo and came is
James Bond which I really should have
taken off before I went to the club
afterwards because I felt like I've lost
weight just being there in that tux and
then today Sunday went to the gym in the
morning and then my parents came up for
a visit so as with them for a couple of
hours came back started filming this few
lovely people so yeah I hope that this
is a bit more representative the past
week because this project so far hasn't
necessarily been terribly representative
and if there's anything you'd like me to
talk about more or less please let me
know because this is ultimately an
access experiment and traditional
vlogging in a sense but accesses the the
overall priority here so if there's
anything you'd like to know like for me
to talk about then please do leave a
message in the comments or send me a
private message whatever yeah this
week's been a bit more normal this is
this is what a normal week kind of looks
like except normally there's a bit more
work than this so maybe next week I'll
do a day a day in the life that video I
will see how it goes because that's
gonna be quite a hassle carrying the
camera around everywhere but yeah you
guys have a good time watching this and
I will see you next week